[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سلاح الماني خطير يدخل الحرب الاوكرانيه
وموسكوتو واسراب المسيرات تملا سماء روسيا
واوكرانيا فلمن ستكون الغلبه وبيضا يعود
بدعم سخي لكياب والامريكان الم تكتفي بعد
ايها العجوز وبصيص امل تركي في معركه
الامعاء الخاويه وبولندا تفقد صاعق صاروخ
على حدود بيلاروسيا وتستعد لنشر عشره الاف
جندي فما الذي يجري القوات الروسيه في
طريقها للالتهام
وسلطات اوكرانيا تعلن حاله الطوارئ القصوى
ومجلس الانقلاب في النيجر يتقدم بخطوه
كبيره والاتحاد الاوروبي يرد زعم كوريا
الشماليه يستعد للحرب وخريطه كوريا
الجنوبيه على مكتبه وبايضا يتحدى الصين
بقرار امريكي جديد
برلين تتحدى موسكو بين الياس والرجاء
يتارجح الامل الغربي بتحقيق انتصارات
اوكرانيه على الارض مقابل الاسلحه التي
يتم تزويدك بها ليعلنها احد اهم الحلفاء
الى الاوكران نعم ونحن نتحدث عن المانيا
والتي كشف حزبها الديمقراطي الاجتماعي
بان برلين ستعلن قريبا قرارها بتزويد
اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده المدى من طراز
التوروس هذه الصواريخ التي طلبتها منذ
اشهر والتي يصل مداها الى 500 كيلومتر
ليتجاوز احفاد هتلر بذلك خطوط بوتين
الحمراء فهل نشهد ردا روسيا مرعبا الامر
لم ينتهي عند ذلك حيث قال الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي مرزيلنسكي في خطاب الله
ان المانيا واوكرانيا اتفقت على توريد
انظمه صاروخيه اضافيه للدفاع الجوي من
طراز باتري الى كياب هيا سخائكم ايه المان
وها نحن نعرض المصدر امامكم كالعاده قال
رئيس الاوكرانيه
على توريد انظمه صاروخيه اضافيه للدفاع
جوي من طراز لكن الالمان يعلمون في قراره
انفسهم ان هذا الدعم ربما سيذهب ادراج
الرياح حيث اكدت صحيفه الالمانيه ان
السلطات الاوكرانيه قلقه من حقيقه انها
ستضطر في القريب العاجل للتفاوض مع روسيا
على خلفيه فشل هجوم قواتها المضاد بعيدا
عن المانيا هناك من لا يكف عن تقديم الدعم
لاوكرانيا انها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يا ساده حيث كشفت صحيفه
بوليتيكو ان الرئيس الامريكي قدم طلبا الى
الكونجرس من اجل الحصول على تمويل جديد
بمليارات الدولارات لتقديمها كمساعدات
عسكريه لاوكرانيا هي فلوس حراميه بهوات
ولا ايه في المقابل يرفض معظم الامريكيين
تقديم الكونجرس تمويلا اضافيا لدعم
اوكرانيا فبحس استطلاع اجرته شبكه سي ان
ان الامريكيه يقول الامريكان لبايدن كفك
لاعبا باقتصادنا ايها العجوز ومن معارك
الدعم والاقتصادي الى حرب المسيره التي
تغطي السماء كالغربان في الحرب الاوكرانيه
لتعلن روسيا اسقاط 11 طائره مسيره قرب شبه
جزيره القرم بالاضافه الى اثنتين كانت
تحلقان باتجاه موسكو وقالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه انه تمت اصابه
بانظمه دفاعيه مضاده للطائرات واخضاع تسعه
طائرات اخرى بوسائل الحرب الالكترونيه وها
هو المصدر يتحدث امامكم اعلنت روسيا اسقاط
13 طائره مسيره اوكرانيه احدى عشره منها
قرب شبه جزيره القرم بالاضافه الى اثنتين
كندا تحلقان باتجاه العاصمه موسكو وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت انه تمت اصابه
طائرتين مسيرتين بانظمه دفاعيه مضاده
للطائرات بالقرب من مدينه سيفا ستوبول
واخضاع تسع طائرات اخرى بوسائل الحرب
الالكترونيه في المقابل اعلنت قياده سلاح
الجو الاوكراني تدمير سبعه طائرات مسيره
روسيه من طراز شاهد خلال 24 ساعه واشارت
قياده سلاح الجو الاوكراني الى انها نفذت
اربعين طالعه جويه على منشات وتجمعات
عسكريه روسيه على الارض قال اندري
ماروتشكو ضابط من قوات جمهوريه لوغانسك ان
الروسيه تتقدم بنجاح في محور كوبي انسك
وتمكنت من تعزيز مواقعها واحراز مزيد من
التقدم في خراكيام مشددا على انه منذ
بدايه هذا الاسبوع في محور كومبيانسك
تمكنت القوات الروسيه من السيطره على ما
يصل الى 20 موقعا للقوات الاوكرانيه ونحو
15 نقطه مراقبه ولذلك اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه في مقاطعه
الاجلاء الالزامي للسكان الى مناطق امنه
وذلك وسط احراز الجيش الروسي مزيدا من
التقدم على هذا المحور في الايام الاخيره
هل اقترب الروس من السيطره على خراكها كما
فعلوا في باك مات ومن رائحه البارود الى
حرب البطون الخاويه حيث كشف مصدر تركي
مطلع على المفاوضات حول صفقه الحبوب ان
انقره تلقت ضمانات شفهيه من الغرب بشان
تصدير منتجات روسيه لكن هذه الضمانات
الشفهيه غير كافيه لاستئناف عمل الصفقه من
جهتها اوكرانيا عن فتح ممرات مؤقته في
البحر الاسود للسفن التجاريه التي تبحر من
والى
موانئسني حيث ان المرور سيكون تحت طائله
مسؤوليه ربان السفينه ومالكها لكن من هو
الربان الذي سيغامر بجعل نفسه هدفا عسكريا
لموسكو ومن اوكرانيا ننتقل نحو الجاره
بولندا حيث اعلن الجيش البولندي عن فقدان
صاعق صاروخ تابع لمروحيه عسكريه على
الحدود مع بيلاروسيا وسط تسير دوريات
عسكريه مكثفه في المنطقه الحدوديه بحثا
عنه بينما اعلن وزير الدفاع البولندي
ماريوس بلاش تشاك في وقت سابق ان بولندا
تعتزم نشر عشره الاف جنديا شرقيا البلاد
لحراسه الحدود مع بيلاروس وفقا نوفوستي
ضغوط الغرب لا تجدي نفعا
النيجر تقلب المعادله في افريقيا
والانقلاب النيجري يفرض الامر الواقع على
الغربيين وفي الوقت الذي اصبحت فيه
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا اقل اهميه
بالنسبه للافارقه بحسب مجله فورن بوليسي
التي اضافت بان دور الجاره نيجيريا يكبر
في المنطقه والتي يصادف ان يكون رئيسها
الجديد الرئيس الحالي لايكونس وعلى ذكر
مجموعه ايكوس فهم اعضاء المجموعه قد
اجتمعوا مره اخرى لبحث قضيه التدخل
العسكري في النيجر لانهاء الانقلاب لكن
دون الافصاح عما دار في اللقاء سوى ما
قاله رئيس نيجيريا بولاتينوبو بانهم
متضامنون مع الشعب النيجر والرئيس بازون
مضيفا بمطالبتهم للقاده العسكريين
بالتراجع عن احتجاز الرئيس اما ما تم
الافصاح عنه فكان من طرف المجلس العسكري
للانقلاب والذي وقع رئيسه عبد الرحمن
الشياني مرسوما بتشكيل حكومه انتقاليه
جديده تضم الحكومه الجديده 21 وزيرا من
شخصيات مدنيه وعسكريه ليضع الانقلاب
الداخلي والخارج امام هذا الامر الواقع
فعلا فهل هناك احتمال لتغيير هذا الوضعيه
ترى شيء اخر تم الافصاح عنه ايضا وهو ما
افادت به روترز بان دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
بدات اولى الخطوات لفرض عقوبات على اعضاء
المجلس العسكري في النيجر الذي استولى على
السلطه الشهر الماضي ولكن هل بامكان
اوروبا ان تفرض طلباتها بواسطه العقوبات
لا اتوا الازمات فماذا ترون انتم الاحداث
والتطورات ذكرت وكاله الانباء المركزيه
الكوريه الشماليه ان الزعيم البلاد كيم
جونغ اون دعا الى المزيد من الاستعدادات
الاحتمال نشوب حرب والى سياده انتاج
الاسلحه وتوسيع نطاق التدريبات العسكريه
مستعرضا امامه خريطه الجاره الجنوبيه فما
الذي يصبو له كام وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
12 طائرات تابعه للقوات الجويه الصينيه
دخلت منطقه الدفاع الجوي للجزيره برفقه
خمس سفن حربيه صينيه تشارك في دوريات
الاستعداد القتالي في ثاني تواغل من نوعه
هذا الاسبوع وفي سياق اخر اصدر الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مرسوما يحضر
الاستثمارات الخارجيه للشركات الامريكيه
في مجالات التكنولوجيا المتقدمه خاصه
الذكاء الاصطناعي والحوسبه الكميه في عده
دول في مقدمتها الصين من جانبها انتقدت
وعرضت القرار الامريكي وبشده مشيره الى ان
هذه القيود تعطل سلاسل الامداد وصفه
القرار بانه اكراه اقتصادي حاد وترهيب في
مجال التكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]